did you know Intel processors brought
personal computers to the home
totally and then Intel made them more
efficient so that you could fit all this
into a laptop tight real tight and then
they help bring Wi-Fi to everybody and
now Intel's best processor ever is here
which helps pcs do things you never
thought possible like time travel Hey
these pants are timeless introducing
Intel's new 6th generation Core
processor it's our best processor ever
what bio mimics do is they say what in
the natural world has already invented
this and then they try to mimic what
they see normally when you say termites
and building you think of termites
eating the buildings but in this case
termites are teaching architects
something termites actually create
buildings of their own those termite
mounds that you see compared to the size
of a termite those are quite large
skyscrapers they're also amazing
ventilation devices termites farm fungus
and so they need to keep that fungus at
a particular temperature 87 degrees
Fahrenheit no matter how hot it gets
outside or how cold it gets outside it
has to be 87 degrees Fahrenheit and they
do this by creating channels inside
their mouths scientists are now
investigating those channels to see if
we can replicate those channels in the
walls of our buildings in order to
increase ventilation in our own
buildings so here you have something so
small as a termite but it's creating a
heating and air conditioning system that
is far more efficient than our
skyscrapers by shaving material use by
working in beautiful coordinated ways
life's learned how to live gracefully on
the planet for more episodes of things
like a tree subscribe to the wired
Channel